weil sich zwei 19 jährige ein illegales
autorennen geben muss eine achtjährige
sterben
die beiden männer sitzen jetzt in u-haft
müssen sich wegen mord verantworten
und über diesen fall möchte ich noch
etwas weiter sprechen mit bild
reporterin birgit begass mir nun auch
zugeschaltet wird sagt uns was genau ist
da passiert
also die haben sie ist auf dieser
eifelstraße auf der annastraße am
dritten august ein rennen geliefert
der bmw-fahrer der der hyundai-fahrer
hat in einer langgezogenen linkskurve
überholt und konnte gerade noch
rechtzeitig bevor ein auto kam und der
bmw fahrer durch nicht mehr geschafft
sondern ist direkt mit geben golf
familien also der familie der vater
mutter den zusammengestoßen und der golf
haft nicht überschlagen und ist in den
wald geflogen und das kind also die
eltern waren schwer verletzt
lebensgefährlich der vater ist
mittlerweile außer lebensgefahr aus und
das achtjährige mädchen ist verstorben
in der klinik jetzt sitzen die beiden
fahrer in untersuchungshaft warum genau
wird das ganze jetzt als mord eingestuft
die staatsanwaltschaft hat nach dem
ermittlungsergebnis andile vorsatz
gehandelt spricht die haben oft
niedrigen beweggründen und gleich
wirklich berg gehandelt und auch mit
vorsatz und deshalb ist das mordmerkmal
und deshalb ist ihr mord angeklagt beide
sitzen in untersuchungshaft beide
autofahrer